hı Hello hepinize Tonguç akademi'den
Merhaba arkadaşlar bugünkü dersimizin
konusu divas Diamond
Divan tage saatleri öğreneceğiz günleri
öğreneceğiz hemen şuradan bir kalem
seçip alıyorum ve hazır saat dersimize
başlıyoruz
neler öğreneceğiz dijitalin font mentiq
besk 14 20'den 100'e kadar olan sayıları
öğreneceğiz div ataykent saatleri
öğreneceğiz bokun tacı günler bir tarif
Saydın günün zamanları Pro pozisyonunu
Mamed atları öğreneceğiz saatleri hangi
edatla günlük hangi edatlar kullanıyoruz
bunları göreceğiz hazır saat devam
ediyoruz Ritalin sonuç Menteş besh 14
şimdi 20'ye kadar olan sayıları adımız
gibi biliyor olmamız gerekiyor ki 20'den
100'e kadar olan sayıları Hatta daha
ilerisini çocuk oyuncağı Ne diyebilirim
saran j20 aynı on trantas hemen 20'den
sonraki sayılarda dikkat etmemiz gereken
nokta önce Sağdaki sayıyı söylüyoruz
yani biri daha sonra da 20 söylüyoruz ve
araya un ve bağlayıcı getiriyoruz 21
aynı tentik 22 sıva yoğun Francis 23
driven ses 24fi ontrans 25 food vantus
26 zevk sunsis 27z bunun fantas 28 aktun
sensiz ve 29 nov and Francis yani dikkat
etmemiz gereken nokta aradaki unut
bağlacını ve bağlıcı unutmuyoruz ve
sayıyı sağdan sola Doğru sondan başa
doğru söylüyoruz Peki diğer bir dikkat
etmemiz gereken nokta ise 20 30 bu onar
onar giden sayıları çok iyi Bilmemiz
gerekiyor 20 biliyoruz santic 30 Driving
40 fiyatı şimdi şurada bir duralım
geldim 30'a şimdi şurada bir duralım 40
dediğimde 40 oluşturabilmek için değilim
ki kırk sayısı aklıma gelmedi Ne
yapacağım bütün sayıları ezberlemiştim
aklıma gelmiyor nereden bulacağım ne
yapıyorum önce önündeki sayı söylüyorum
Çünkü neden ben 20'ye kadar olan
sayıları adım gibi biliyorum 4 neydi
fiyat 40 diyebilmem için sadece sonuna
hazi kekin ekliyorum fiyat ikv ezik diye
telaffuz etmiyorum Sadece oradaki geceye
Yarın bir şey gibi telaffuz ediyorum
fiyat şey fiyati Peki aynı şey 14 için
söyleyelim Mesela örnek verelim ve
bilgilerimizi bir hatırlayalım geçmiş
bilgilerimizi 14 diyebilmem için diyelim
ki 14 aklıma gelmedi ne ya o ilk önce
doğru söylemem gerekiyor Fi'a ve onu
sayılarda eklediğimde senin fiyatı bakın
14 aklıma gelmemiş Olabilir ama ben 4'ü
bildiğim için yani 20'ye kadar da olmaz
12'ye kadar bildiğim için ben 12 den
sonrasını da gayet yapabiliyorum fiyatı
istediğimde 40 Peki 41 diyeceğim Aynı Az
önce 20'li sayıları okuduğumuz gibi 41
demek için önce biri söylüyorum Aynen un
fiyat iş ayın on filtre ve bitişik
yazıyorum ayın on fiyat iş geldim 30'a
en son kutu bırakmıştık 30'a geldim
30'da bir istisna var Nedir bu istisna
mzik olarak yazmıyorum da şu garip uzun
kuyruklu B harfi ile yazıyorum ve aynı
şekilde okuyorum drahy Sting ama T
şeklinde okuyorum Drive safe Drive Sea
40 fiyatı Shell lif ülfiş pek bu işe
geldim Burada bir istislam var Normalde
Altın neydi zevk Yani sonunda bir s
harfi var ama buraya geldiğimde 60
derken s harfi düşüyor ve zeks iş olarak
okuyorum 70 dediğimde 7 neydi dizi ben
yine 70 derken xerbıbın da ki eve ne
harfleri düşüyor cips xe80 derken Ah seç
90 Noel
1814 ya da aynı honderd diyebilirim
mesela 200 diyeceğim Aynı yerine yazmam
gerekiyorsa Vice Vay hundar Yani aslında
sayıların mantığını anladığınızda hiç
ezberleme nize gerek kalmayacak o zaman
Son sürat devam ediyoruz ve saatlere
geliyoruz saatleri iki başta bölerek
söyledi Yani iki ana başlıkta
kullanıyoruz birincisi dilin ofise livat
Sait yani resmi olmayan saatler Günlük
kullandığımız geçe kala buçuklu saatler
kullanır var yani günlük kullandığımız
saatlerde inofix eluat al kullanıyoruz
Dyo fitili ovaser dediğimizde ise resmi
saatler yani dijital saatler den
bahsediyorum Saat ve dakika ya söyledim
geç eve kala kullanmadığım saatlerden
Peki saatleri öğrenebilmek için önce
niye bilmem gerekiyor kelimeleri bilmem
gerekiyor diye dua saat suak alana geç
Efor kelimesinin Yani kara kelimesinin
daha akılda kalıcı olması için şimdi
size bir ipucu söylüyorum Fuad erken
Bunu sanki var gibi düşünün yani
kalavar şeklinde kullandığımızda hangi
kelimeyi kullanıyor muyuz fuar kelimesi
Nina geçe fiyatın çeyrek fiyatının Fuat
çeyrek kala fiyatına çeyrek geçe Help
buçuk nahal buçuğu geç Efo halk buçuğa
kadar şimdi son iki kelimem İzin ne
olduğunu birazdan göreceğiz bu etlerdeki
Bu iki kelime Türkçe'de çok fazla
kullanmıyoruz Peki saatleri nasıl
soracağız diş fetus saat kaç bakın
saatimin etrafında 2'ye böldüm saatimi
bu tarafım Geçen Ah Bu tarafın kala yani
var fuar ve buçuklu saatleri söylerken
de hal kelimesinden yardım olur şimdi
örneklerimiz ile biraz daha iyi
anlayacağız Az önce saat sorarken hangi
kalıbı kullandık bir şüphe test Biz saat
sorarken iki farklı kalıp kullanabiliriz
bicipitis saat kaç wifi Luis test yine
saat kaç anlamına geliyor cevabınız ise
tek bir cevap Eses araya sayımızı
ekliyoruz saatimizin kaç olduğunu
ekliyoruz ve sonra da saat anlamına
gelen uğa kelimemiz ekliyoruz Öncelikle
Dino fitre liova Tayt konumuzu bir
inceleyelim yani resmi olmayan saatlere
ses Fuat bu saatleri söylerken sonuna
her zaman uva kelimesini getirmeliyiz et
fango 5.00 seksualna 6.00 şeklinde Peki
Eses Ey fua phia saat dörde on var
derken bakın on var kalan afua
kelimesini kullanıyorum ve cümlenin En
sonuna o kelimesini eklemiyorum yani fua
kalana geçe olarak kullandığım saatlerde
o kelimesini kullanmıyorum Sadece tam
saatleri söylerken bu kelime hem
söylüyorum hem de yazıyorum Peki Eses
One Siz nahn ol saat
9.20 sven seç nahn oyna neydi geceydi
pg&e ses fiyatın Fuat Vay fiyatı neydi
çeyrekteki fittolife olduğunda çeyrek
var ya da çeyrek kala diyoruz saat 1.45
E siz fiyatına ha bu Es fiyatına alt
Peki fiyatın çeyrektir fiyatı poğaça
çeyrek var ya da çeyrek kala fiyatının
ofise şuradan Hemen kontrol ediyoruz ne
dememiz gerekiyor çeyrek geçe Yani saat
8.15 ve saatleri söylerken cümle
kalıbımız neydi
es-es'te cümlemize başlıyoruz bir Filo
Eses Vikipedi'si Test olarak da
saatimizi soruyoruz Son sürat devam
ediyoruz buçuklu saatleri söylerken
dikkat etmemiz gereken tek bir nokta var
Bir saat sonrasını söylüyoruz Yani altı
buçuk saatini söylemek istediğimizde
altı yerine yediği söylüyoruz hemen
örneğimizde en bakalım Eses harp zibi
şimdi cümlemizden xerbıbın yazıyor yani
yedi harp 7.30 anlamam gerekiyor ama ne
yapıyorum yazan cümledeki sayının bu bu
hepsini
söylerken ise artı bir ekleyerek
söylüyorum Yani saat 6.30 demem için
altı yerine ne yapıyorum artı bir
ekledim 7 olarak söylüyorum e-test harp
zaman saat 7.30 essayist ne yapıyorum 7
artı bir ekliyorum 8 diyorum Eses harp
aht saat 5.30 ne yapıyorum eski ses harp
w5100 sayısını yani artı 1 rakamını
ekliyorum harp zeks Saat beş buçuk saat
dokuz buçuk dokuz ekle üstüne artı biri
essayist Ne diyeceğim ona diyeceğim yani
cümlemde on yazacağım ama anlarken bir
eksiğini anlayacağım Eses halp şeyin
saat 9.30 11.30 ne yapıyorum esis
kalıbımı yazıyorum cümlemi başını
yazıyorum ve 10 o zamanın bir üst
rakamını söylüyorum Eses
harp ver saat 11 buçuk saat 12.30 12
artı bir ekle
esharp ay and saat 12.30 yani dikkat
etmemiz gereken nokta ve asla
unutmamamız gereken nokta buçuklu
saatler de artı bir ekliyoruz ana saatin
üzerine artı bir ekliyoruz bakın Hiç
korkulacak birşey yokmuş o zaman Son
sürat devam ediyoruz Peki nedir bu
buçuklu saatlerin Bir de buçuğu olması
yani buçuğu geçe buçuğa kalan nedir
bunlar Biz Türkçede kullanmıyoruz
Aslında Almanca'da çok sık kullanılmıyor
ama bilgi bilgidir aklınızın bir
köşesinde kalsın Peki geldim örneğim Ee
ses friend Nah hepsi bin haczi ben
dediğimde Ne yapıyordum bir eksiğini
anlıyordum cümlenin içinde gördüm
sayının bir eksiğini anlamam gerekiyor
ya ya Saat 6.30 peki burada fınn Ah var
bir geçe var bir harf var bir sayı var
Saat altı buçuğu beş geçiyor yani altı
30'u beş dakika geçmiş
6.35 dakika geçmişe ses fınt nahh artzie
Ben Peki yan tarafa geldim Eses fünf o
Akal anlamına geliyordu herkesi bakın
Saat 6.30 5 var peki burada ne anlamam
gerekiyor benim yani Saat 6.30 6.30
olmasına beş dakika kalmış Saat 6.30
olmasına beş dakika kaldı 8/35
Yukarıdaki Sizce hangi örnekleri uyu
8/35 saat sekiz buçuğu beş dakika geçmiş
nahee ses fıns nahadna on sekiz buçuk
diyebilmem için 8001/3 sayısını söyle ne
diyordu yani dokuz dönmem gerekiyor Noel
her gün oyun dediğimde 8.30 ama beş
dakika geçtiğini söylemem gerekiyor Feel
Now harp Noel saat sekiz buçuğu beş
geçiyor peki 15-25 Ne demem gerekiyor Bu
da ne anlamam gerekiyor Saat üç buçuğa
beş dakika var yani saatin 3.30 olmasına
beş dakika var Ne kullanmam gerekiyor
falan var kala kullanmam gerekiyor Eses
fua harfi A üç buçuk diyebilmem için
3'ün 1/3 sayısını söyleyeceğim fiya
helfi ya dediğimde üç buçuk ama üç buçuk
kaç dakika var Beş dakika var esis fua
harfi ya Saat üç buçuğa 5 var Beş dakika
kaldı Okey Son sürat devam ediyoruz Ben
şuradan bir kalemimi değiştireyim
Birazcıkta kırmızıyı kullanmak istiyorum
saatteki ara dakikaları söylemek
istediğimizde yine kalıbımız aynı esiste
cümleye başlıyoruz bu fuara Akalay Adana
gece kelimelerini kullanıyoruz ama
dakikalı saati söylerken cümlemiz de
kalıp cümlemizden önce dakika yı sonra
saati söylüyoruz Peki örneğimizde
bakalım 12.08 Yani benim önce dakikayı
söylemem gerekiyor Daha sonrada en son
cümlenin en sonunda saati belirtmem
gerekiyor es-es'e taht Nah sörf saat
12.08 na neydi geçe poğa kala hemen yan
örneği M geçiyorum 18-55
Eses öntes buazizi Wan saat 6.55 yani
Beş dakika sonra 7.00 olacak 9-10 geldim
bunuda birlikte yapalım 9-10 diyebilmem
için ne yapıyorum hemen buraya 9'u
gösteriyorum ve ne eklemem gerekiyor
dakikaya eklemem gerekiyor Yani şuradan
da hemen Şuraya bir O çok çıkartıyorum
ne yapıyorum
9.10 demem lazım ne yapacağım Eses
kalıbımı yazıyorum ve cümleye başlıyorum
önce dakikayı söylemem gerekiyor dakikam
neon senin ne yapıyor peki
9.10 Yani Nah kullanmam gerekiyor Es
etsin
namun saat
9.10 Evet Son sürat devam ediyoruz diye
ofisleri olsa yani dijital saatler den
bahsedeceğiz resmin saatlerden
bahsedeceğiz fua
kalana geçe gibi terimleri
kullanmayacağız Peki kalıbı nasıl aynı
şekilde esest hemen araya saati
getiriyorum önce araya Ova kelimesi
ekliyorum saat anlamına gelen ve en sona
dakikaya getiriyorum yani dijital Saate
baktığımızda şöyle söylüyoruz ya Saat
kaç Saat 8.50 saat 8.55 aynı şekilde
önce Saati söylüyor daha sonra dakikayı
söylüyorum Unutmam gereken şey araya Ova
kelimesi geliyor 8.50 es-es'e aht saati
söyledim ara o kelime mi getirdim 50
geçiyor fönsüz bu yüzden de 100'e kadar
sayıları biliyor olmam gerekiyor 11.20
ne yapıyorum eze ses önce saati
söylüyorum Elif hua
20'si renting saat 11 20 14.35 ne
yapıyorum yine kalıbımı yazıyorum Eski
son 4 neydi fiyat
sinara yana getiriyorum UEFA ve 35 demem
lazım fındık uzun
Driving
contraiis saat
14.35 20.45 ne yapıyorum 8 olarak da
yazabilirim 20 olarak da yazabilirim
daha çok 8 kullanacağım en bu test ahua
önce saati yazıyorum ahua 45 demem lazım
dakikam 45 Çünkü dakikamı da yazıyorum
full un fiyatı 45 Siz Ah tuhaf ön fiyatı
22.30 saat on buçuk 22.30 da diyebilirim
yani 22 sayısında kullanabilirim ama
saat on buçukta diyebilirim O zaman ne
yazıyorum kalıbımı Aynı şekilde
Esse şeyin u.a.e. Drive sis saat
bu
22.30 ama ben de kullandım 10.30
kullandım Eses Senin o adra ise 22
kullanalım eseslim Advance vaat rysy
saat 22.30 15 25 bin aynı şekilde 3.25
olarak kullanabilirim Eses Drive a
söz 10 painting Strike a full Advantage
Of peki 17 15 yine v şeklinde
kullanıyorum Es
ün fuar full Scene Saat beş on beş
altı 10saat 6.10 ama ben dijital saatler
den bahsediyorum yani ofislere
saatlerden bahsediyorum O zaman ne
yapacağım dijital saatleri söylediğim
gibi söylemem gerekiyor esest zevk suyu
Oo kelimesini asla unutmuyorum Hatta
Şuraya bir yıldız bu
Eslek su asin diyorum ve Dijital
saatlerde söylemeyi anında kalktım Son
sürat devam ediyoruz Ben Pro pozisyonu
mum edatı ne zaman kullanıyorum
saatlerde kullanıyorum hangi soruyla
kullanıyorum One sorusuyla yani ne zaman
anlamına gelen zaman soruyorum ne zaman
One ne zaman zaman sorarken One sorusunu
kullanıyoruz Evet peki One sorusunun
cevabını da ise saati söylerken yani
zaman belirtirken um edatı kullanıyoruz
Zoom edatı cümleye davete anlamını
veriyor hemen örneğimizde bakalım
wifiloo estate Saat kaç cevabınız da
belirli bir zaman söylemeliyiz esest
sıva yuva burada bir zamanımız var edat
kullanmamıza gerek yok ama örneğimizde
bizden direkt saati istediği için bizde
karşılığında bu direkt olarak Saati
söylüyor yani zamanı söylüyoruz Peki ne
zaman diye sorduğunda Ne kullanmam
gerekiyor saatimin önünde daha de anlamı
veren um edatını kullanmam gerekiyor One
Games buna havuz Eve ne zaman gidiyorsun
bakın zaman istiyor bizden tam bir zaman
istiyor ilişki o unzile benua saat 7'de
eve gidiyorum iş ki onun zivoll Yani ben
One gördüğümde One sorusu Bey fragman
lardan olan One sorusunu gördüğümde
cevabın da saatimin önüne un edatını
getirmeliyim One come to Ne zaman
geliyorsun tam bir saat istiyorum saat
kaçta geliyorsun ilk
omeon kaçta geliyormuş ne yapıyorduk 12
sayısı yani 12'nin 13 sayısını
söyleyeceğiz artı bir ekleyeceğiz harp
aynı hemen ekleyelim Buraya yazalım harp
Einstein o zaman Holland diyebilirim
Yada iş com'un tripod Racing bu şekilde
telaffuz edebiliyorum ne zaman
geliyormuş saat 12 buçukta geliyormuş O
zaman um edatının saatlerde
kullanıldığını artık biliyoruz ne
yapıyoruz One sorusunu gördüğümüzde
oğlum edatıyla de da anlamı vererek
cümlemizi oluşturuyoruz o zaman Son
sürat devam ediyorsa günlere geldik
divon taa günler kaç tane günümüz var
yedi tane günümüz var pazartesi mont
arsalı din sat Çarşamba Metro ter şembe
donana Start Cuma Say tak cumartesi
zantar pazar zontak Peki aynı saatlerde
olduğu gibi günleri de cümle içerisinde
kullanılırken bir edattan yardım
alıyoruz hangi Eda tam Vedat'ı Amon tak
Pazartesi günü var Yani cümleye de da
anlamı katıyor cuma gününde Cuma günü
Amon tak Pazartesi günü ya da pazartesi
de pazartesi gününde amdin Sarpa
metrohan döner Selam Paytak Hamza'm stad
unam zonta günlerin artikeli der yani
değer zontak de zam Start bu şekilde
Artık yeni unutmuyoruz günler her zaman
büyük harfle başlıyor ve iki tane daha
ekstra bir kelime öğrenelim Divo Hunter
gi7 tane günümüzün hepsini kapsıyor peki
Hafta içi demek istediğimiz dedi abayt
Savcı Yani iş günleri beş günü Cup suyu
pazartesinden cumaya kadar belki de
swoon hem de hafta sonu anlamına geliyor
hangi günleri kapsıyor zamsalak
cumartesi zontak pazartesi yani günlerde
dikkat etmemiz gereken bu orta edat
unutmamak ve artık elinin değer olduğunu
unutmamak O Zaman hızlıca günlerde
bitirdiğimizde göre Dersimize devam
ediyoruz deter gas aydın Günün zamanları
akşam öğlen öğleden önce öğleden sonra
Örneğin de Morgan sabah anlamına geliyor
dönme tak öyle de abent akşam deformite
tak öğleden önceden Ahmet Tak öğleden
sonra ve dinle laf gece dikkat ederseniz
sabah öğle akşam öğleden önce böyle den
sonraki gün zamanlarında artık elimiz
der bir tek istisna olarak gece der
Kendi artık eline kullanıyoruz Dina aynı
şekilde a Morgan sabah sabahleyin sabah
vakitlerinde amfo mitonne öğleden önce
Ahmet Tak öyle ya da öyleyim de
diyebiliriz Anne Ahmet Abi öğleden var
ama ben akşam akşamleyin akşam
vakitlerinde Burada yine bir istisna mız
var az önce ne dedik gece kelimesinde
diğer kendi kullanıyoruz aynı şekilde
edat kullanırken Yani daha de anlamı
veren edatı kullanırken de in der nacht
diyoruz Allah demiyoruz indir na gecede
geceleyin gece vakitlerinde Peki
günlerde olduğu gibi günün zamanlarında
da ne yapıyoruz aynı edatı kullanıyoruz
ve zaman bildirdiği içinde One sorusuyla
sorumuzu sorabiliriz Evet günün
zamanlarında bitirdik günleri öğrendik
saatleri öğrendik Son sürat devam
ediyoruz Eğer bütün olarak yapılan
işlerde günleri ve günün zamanlarını
kullanıyorsak baş harflerini küçük
yazıyoruz ve Kelimenin sonuna e s takısı
getiriyoruz ne demek bu Es takısı
morgans bakın baş harfi küçük ve
sabahları anlamına geliyor bu anlam O
hangi ek sonundaki S2 s harfi morgans
Sabahları Format at öğleden önceleri
vitox öğlenlerin Ahmet Aksöz öğleden
Sonraları abent akşamları naht geceleri
Peki neden küçük yazıyorum çünkü
rutinleri günlerden ayırmam gerekiyor
belirli bir günde yaptığım bir
aktiviteyi belirtmem için Çünkü aynı gün
her zaman o aktiviteyi yapıyorum mesela
Sabahları spor yapıyorum Morgan işte
Pazartesileri spor yapıyorum montex
salıları arkadaşlarımla buluşuyorum din
Stark yani her zaman olan butin
etkinliklerimizde biz ne yapıyoruz baş
harfini küçük yazıyoruz Ve sonuna ev
takısı ekliyoruz aynı şekilde montex
dedik Pazartesileri Deniz tarz salıları
donor saks perşembe Allah rahmet boks
atladık meatbox çarşambaları freetuxtv
cumaları zam Stark cumartesileri zorteks
pazar günleri Peki zamanı sordum hangi
soruyla soruyordum One nereye diye
soracağım Nereye wohen Nereye ve fragman
lardan Bohem sorusu ne yapıyor bu soru
ne Anlam katıyor hareket bildiriyor bir
eylem var Ne demem gerekiyor okula
gidiyorum Sinemaya gidiyorum Eve
gidiyorum denize gidiyorum demem
gerekiyor o zaman indi Şule okula
gidiyorum ins Kino Sinemaya gidiyorum
kinosi ne mana havuzu eve gidiyorum
Annem esmeya hemen kısaltı yorum
buradaki iki artık elveda tımı a and m&a
and As Kafein scaf İpek örneklerine
geldim Lion git Morgan di Şule Leon ne
yapıyor Sabahları o o okula gidiyor bu
he Nereye Okula gidiyor ne zaman bakın
hemen şöyle yazalım bu hem nereye indi
Şule Ben fen Morgan Sabahları rutin
olarak yaptığı için ne yapıyorum baş
harfini küçük yazıyorum sonunu Astra
kısa ekliyorum yani her sabah Leon okula
gidiyor morgans git Leon indir Şule
şimdi bu iki cümle arasındaki farklılığa
bir bakalım yapınız oluşturulmuş cümle
yapısı nasıl Leon git morgan-dew Şule
derken Leon Benim Özlem ben özne ile
başladım cümleye ve Daha sonrasında ne
demiştik her zaman ikinci pozisyona fiil
getiriyoruz özneye göre çekim leyerek ve
sonra da zaman getirdim Peki zamanı başı
aldım cümleye başladığım için baş harfin
Tabii ki büyük olacak Morgan hiç ayırt
etmeden Ne yapıyorum İki pozisyonda
cümlemin iki pozisyonda yine fiilimi bu
getiriyorum Kime göre çekiniyorum L Ona
göre yani özneye göre çekiniyorum yani
zamanı başı alarak da cümle yapımızı
oluşturan biliriz mor gasquet Leon indir
Şule eşya bam Donas tak aynı powerpunk
ufong sınav anlamına geliyor ne zaman
sınavım var banam döner Sak Perşembe
günü eş habe Ağam dinstar Kaynın Tamil
Neyin var randevum var
randevu bir randevum var ne zaman vanam
din stad Salı günü Eh bezu hikay tarz
Mynet elten kimi ziyaret ediyorum bez
ruhun ziyaret etmek anlamına geliyor
kimi ziyaret ediyorum mangal Sen ailemi
ziyaret ediyorum Ne zaman One Fight Aks
ne yapıyorum
kaytar ne yapıyorum burada da root Bu
bir işten bahsettiğim için bir
aktiviteden bahsettiğim için yani
cumaları ailemi ziyaret ediyorum her
cuma bunu rutin olarak yapıyorum o
yüzden ne yapıyorum sonuna el takısı
ekliyorum pek Eee fare Hamza'm sakın ah
İstanbul cumartesi günü nereye gidiyorum
Nah İstanbul İstanbul'a gidiyorum Eşme
hem zontak piknik ne yapıyorum piknik
yapıyorum peki Amazon takvan pazar günü
yani Bilmem gereken nokta günlerle
saatlerin önünde hangi adada kullandığım
ve rutin işlerimi söylerken de günlerine
yapıyorum sonuna s takısı ekliyorum aynı
şekilde günün zamanlarında da sonuna de
takıp bekliyorum o zaman devam edelim ve
ödülü sorumuza geçelim vanko mstu abın
na havuzu ne zaman eve en son Akşamları
bakın Her akşam bu dinlen bahsediyorum s
takısı var ne zaman One konuştu Abant da
howze ne zaman akşamları Ne zaman eve
geliyorsun Evet Bu cümlenin tam cevabını
yorumlara bekliyorum Bir sonraki derste
görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın o
[Müzik]